[Music]
this article
is for the tall girls in the room
because there's so many i'm just kidding
for dio
because i'm listening did you all wish
you were tall i'm all the way up here
i'm listening i don't care we're talk
about girls oh no i mean you can
participate it's okay it's not for girls
only
i always used to hear that girls were
like i wish i was taught and i'm like no
you don't stop it
well uh this teenager the 17 year old
has just broken the guinness world
record
for two titles the law for having the
longest female legs and the long
longest teenage lakes wow
thank you teenage lady congratulations
how how tall is she she is six foot 10.
oh what's considered teenage
is it up until 19. she has some great
legs girl
is is now that's 13 to 19 teenagers oh
my goodness
well her mom's tall as [ __ ] too though
her mom is five
nine i think that's not that though i
guess that's her legs
are as tall as me oh my goodness how how
oh how tall is the tallest person how
tall is
like eight feet or something like that
it's like pretty tall yeah i don't
answer everyone's question at the same
time i could answer that one she's six
ten so her
how tall is a tall size tall at
starbucks
20 ounces no it's not that's a venti
it's like 16 ounces she knows so the
father
is six foot five the mother is five foot
seven
and she's significantly taller than both
of them her legs the dad's tall as [ __ ]
already though six
foot five is pretty damn tight yeah that
is really tall
her brother's 19 uh he's older than her
and
she uh he's six three i think oh that
sucks your sister's
seven inches taller than anything and
then so her legs sixty's tolerant too
for real [ __ ] her legs make up sixty
percent of her total height
wow wow yeah is that normal i don't know
what
what the no what are the ratios what is
the normal ratio her legs like
as tall as us because i feel like that
should be normal right because it's not
like it's 50 50.
can you put your uh [ __ ] feet behind
your head no
try that one yeah you can do it right
there
it hurts damn you're pretty flexible you
can actually do it yeah push for it
i can't do this one [ __ ] okay [ __ ] fine
oh [ __ ] you're putting it do it yeah
no no it hurts dad you'd be a tenth
planet prodigy
for real yeah why do you always want to
tie it how he went straight to jiu jitsu
instead of instead of saying i'm a [ __ ]
he's so good he's like oh my god you'd
be good at jesus
because i already put you in there i'm
going to shoot my sex life i'll put you
in those positions
i can't do it baby yeah you're pretty
close i'm already flexible though
how do you guys even get there ponytail
it's pretty good that's pretty
look at your [ __ ] feet dude i don't
wear shoes
joe's like hell of a police drive so
hard yeah way more flexible with my
wrist that [ __ ] is nowhere near his head
joe's like i'm so close guys
how do you get there how about like
touching your hand like this
oh bart for sure can't do that you do
buff
how do you get there how do you get
there
i can't do it oh i could touch them do
the other thing all you
drop your turn around to show the camera
oh yeah the other way you're more
flexible
oh how did you even get there well you
just get that
stretch he doesn't stretch he just
stretched
[Laughter]
but yeah so her right leg measures
53.255 inches
you'll be pretty good at jiu-jitsu yeah
instead of like i'm a [ __ ] is so good
this is for all of us to think badly
uh but yeah so she her legs actually
measure differently
the right leg measures at 53.2 inches so
she walks like a [ __ ] peg
a lot of us have that yeah that's super
normal yeah how many inches off
her left leg is 52.874 inches so it's
like an inch
that's pretty normal yeah slightly damn
yeah so she actually has to get
clothing uh especially made for her if
she's wearing pants of course she's a
giant
hey hey we don't appreciate those terms
all right she's 16. she's
tall she's 6 10. giants are not
uh it's not a good thing okay so on her
tick tock she self
identifies as ceo of giraffes
she's very proud of her her height and i
love her
and and so she's pretty much saying like
she's advocating for self
self and she's usually using hashtags
like
perfect as i am yep she does a lot of
tick tocks you know what's so
interesting she's actually doing
something that's very
uh counter cultural clown cultural to
what's going on now
because now it's not about accepting who
you are i have money i can change
what i want [ __ ] you that's actually the
end thing now
if you say filters if you say accept me
as i am now people the backlash that is
well what if somebody wants to change
their face it's their body they could do
whatever they want
which is so odd because i thought the
positive thing to say
is like look you're beautiful the way
you are and just love yourself that's
what bruno mars said and i believe him
it's the other way it's like well if i
want to [ __ ] get surgery here and do
this who are you to tell me i
i it's it's i i'm not beautiful this way
i don't know i don't i don't know if
they're opposites or they mean
what a crazy one whoever whatever you
want to do it makes you happy that's
what you get to do you just don't do
that and
people don't judge you for it they
should just have you i wished it was
like that though they should just have
me
tell them if they're hot or not yeah
dude
like just ask joe ask joe okay yeah hey
joe would you [ __ ] me yeah
all right so i have a video
showing um oh my goodness i didn't even
tell you her name
macy macy curran kieran no
she gets the best views at concerts
she's gonna be no
look at her leg her boyfriend's shoulder
at a rave
she would even be able to see like from
way far
behind the stage yeah if she's on her
boyfriend's shoulder she might be lower
touch the ground on the boyfriend's
shoulder yeah then where she actually is
that's a good point
so she's from texas which um everything
is bigger
yeah i was like oh thank goodness she's
there because then like all the homes
are really big like everything like
there's
some high ceilings right there bigger
gas stations
bigger cars big horses
wow she's awesome
whoa oh yeah that's that 610.
wow i first noticed
i was taller than everyone like in
preschool
i was introduced to people and i was
like taller than everyone at my
preschool
i never really had a single growth spurt
where i grew a lot
i grew about like four to five inches a
year whoa
normally getting taller kids grow about
two inches ago she plays volleyball
that's not fair yeah that's not fair
yeah of course she'd be a middle blocker
hell yeah
me too girl i just stopped caring that's
awesome i did buy anything
that's awesome oh she had great parents
tall women can see
that the heart is a gift
yep and that you shouldn't be ashamed
tall
you should really embrace it that's
awesome you know what would suck
if you were tall and ugly oh because
everybody has to see it but she's tall
and she's cute
so like it doesn't it's like cool
explain your thought process real quick
who's joe jones well i'm just i'm just
kind of pointing out the obvious right
like it's better if you're short and
ugly yeah cause you could hide better
right yeah because no one could see you
yeah you're just gonna
go in a crowd and you're gone so it is
what you're saying is exactly what i'm
saying
well you go behind a coffee table and
you're going to me i have the beholder
joe
yeah bozo yours yeah i didn't even call
her ugly i said she's pretty
i know but i'm just saying you're both
insulting people that you think are ugly
and tall
you guys don't think there's ugly people
but i hate to be careful what you were
gonna say
because you're insulting some [ __ ]
ugly ass people right now
hey all i'm saying is we all like you're
right the beauty is in the eye the
beholder someone out there thinks i'm
ugly as [ __ ] that's okay
but i'm saying that it would suck right
it would really suck
if you were talking i think it just
sucks if you're ugly yeah
period all right well [ __ ] doesn't
matter if you're tall or short for guys
it's kind of the opposite though like if
you're
ugly but tall then you're tall then
you're automatically that much more
handsome oh that's true
really it's it's honestly like people
really are
beautiful or ugly based off of how their
personalities are more than they are
sure that's exactly how i feel to a
certain extent
i trumped it man well for sure but you
have to get to know somebody first to
understand you don't have time to get to
know the world
you're thinking damn [ __ ] i mean
you could get like a solid five minutes
talking to someone you couldn't but most
people don't get that
so when you when they're just walking
down i don't know [ __ ] about jason mamoa
but i can
tell that he's a fine [ __ ] even
me there's a difference though
because i can tell that jason momoa is
attractive but i'm not attracted to him
i'm attracted to jesus because you have
problems honestly i'm more attracted to
his personality than his looks i don't
even know you don't even know
he watches interviews and go oh my god
i'm wet he's such a sweetheart and then
the way he loves his family is just so
[ __ ] cute like that's honestly the
thing that attracts me the most you
follow us
and then i love how he's married to my
[ __ ] childhood crush too
are they is there a big size difference
between oh yeah
yeah he carries her she has a strap on
her back and he's like let's go baby
it's like a purse little luggage straps
on her that's cute
yeah she's like my height like those
like those baby best things
i think she's my height yeah so he's
five four i think so i could be wrong
lisa steve's a foot taller than me
a foot a whole phone yeah oh wow 12
inches
that's a lot just like his dude
that's right girl sent her to the
hospital baby
i don't know if i'm just weird but i
don't even think that it's such a big
deal
that a girl is just massively tall like
i don't think it's like a bad trait to
have because if you think about
models or athletes they're super [ __ ]
super tall
and then it's a good it's a positive
trait like thank you
it's not like i would say like the the
opposite would be being extremely short
like a little person like who would have
ever roasted you that you were 5 11.
like i don't understand how that's a
rose like oh my god geo's tall have
people made fun of you growing up that
you're tall
um yeah i mean they'll make fun of you
for anything so yeah
yeah looks like it but it's like how
does that even sound like a giant
like yeah like yo you're a giant giraffe
so many times
yeah but that's just because i'm making
fun of stuff about her that's not really
offensive
but it was something that was actually
offensive i would never say that i could
get how they feel out of place
yeah because what if like her height is
sensitive you don't know well then she's
just being a dumbass
but what if it's it to me it's like
making her know someone for being rich
like tall is a trait that you want right
so then
well peop rich kids get picked up too
but i know but that's
why it doesn't really stick though you
know what i mean it's like it's like
you can't really be like people make so
much fun of me because i'm so beautiful
yeah i mean she's done that before but
it's a little weird
it is hard it is hard but you wouldn't
understand [ __ ] hard times
thank you baby a lot of tall people get
um slouching problems because
like in while they're growing up they
try to fit in with their peers
oh really so they get used to doing this
yeah because they kind of just want to
do this but it was for me i had terrible
posture because everybody's [ __ ]
short and vietnamese around me
no man come down here i'm like okay [ __ ]
man
leave me ten secrets even more
man i know i can't hear nothing when i
go to my filipino side i tower over
everyone it's so you know
yeah i'm 5'4
[Music]
you